je s'équipe d'un direct avec brut était
l'artiste français le plus écouté de la
décennie on sait ça ça fait plaisir et
ça c'est ça aussi c'est une récompense
c'est la récompense de tout mon travail
je pense parce que j'ai travailé dur
c'est un parcours de fond parce que je
me dis que avant avancé 6 ans là que ça
fait six ans que je suis un peu fait peu
connu avant ça j'ai aussi travaillé
beaucoup ce moment tu as eue dans ma
chambre je restais j'ai beaucoup lu
beaucoup travaillé je voulais en fait le
travail c'est tout en fait il faut
doubler au bois à vérité c'est une
drogue chimique c'est ça devant tout le
monde comme ça ceux qui aiment leur
travail ils sont plus longs fatigants ce
huitième ce que tu fais c'est un travail
après tu sens la fatigue et toux ya tout
à manger les yeux j'ai le bas du dos
j'ai hâte a tué le cerveau et les
petites douleurs tues le centre du tout
sans que quand tu vas vivre
qu'est ce qui va se passer mes yeux j'ai
pu revoir je suis devant l'ordi comme ça
c'est ça le dg de l'ensci et je voyais
avec les lentilles il y à charner roche
passer un moment donné envie de te dire
que fo se demande quand est-ce qu'ils
dorment fat le sujet à 6 heures du matin
ils m'appellent 2h du matin
catastrophe at il déjà après il ya des
annonces effacé lui l'artiste et c'est
lui qui donne moins que nous aucun
moment donné faut dormir tu fais plus de
deux mille sont déjà j'ai fait beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de sens parce
que chaque fois sur dix albums de 20 23
24 des fois sur des doubles albums de 40
je me dis que je vais garder ce rythme
mais par exemple là tu vois on va dire
jusqu'à je vais pas dire la date mais je
vais faire une bonne petite pause
histoire qu'on se repose qu'on écoute un
peu tous les sens que j'ai pu sortir
qu'ils aient le temps un peu tu as envie
de déguster les arbres et on déguste et
bien prenez votre temps et tout spécial
vélodrome il faut tout mémoriser
je vais être trois quatre mois un fonds
dont concert quoi bon sens ça va être à
fond franchement je crois que c'est ça
va être le plus beau jour de ma vie même
on va dire ça va être un des plus beaux
jours de ma vie parce que
en fait c'est ya toute une histoire
derrière le vélodrome mois sans voir que
avant la musique
quand j'avais par wind un secteur je
travaille et je fais la sécu au stade
vélodrome avant de faire la sécu au
stade vélodrome j'ai fait ramasseurs de
balle et une histoire est une histoire
avec le louvre les critiques semblent
donc en force à une critique pas
immunisés problème est là il amusé mi
mai que l'auto tune ils me cassent les
oreilles avec auto tune
au final je peux leur dire merci aussi
parce que il parle de moi et je remercie
continuez donc le plaisir je rigole
quand je veux comme et et a+ a plu dans
l'est comme dans les vidéos je vous vois
aussi mais surtout merci matching qui me
suivent qui me soutiennent dans tous les
moments qui vous accueillent aux idées
des mauvais truc sûrement des trucs et
tous merci à ceux qui me soutiennent
ceux qui sont avec moi qui marche pas
parce que moi je vous lâcherai pas aussi
[Musique]
car si des rues du hip hop